le monde sait squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur un jeu what the fuck tout
comme avant-hier mais cette fois c'est
un jeu largement plus drôle pour vous
dire à l'heure actuelle c'est le jeu
selon moi qui est le plus drôle tout
simplement et le plus débile
alors on va les jouer tout de suite
alors je vais tout vous expliquer un peu
les règles du jeu qui sont totalement qu
alors en fait le contrôle du petit
bonhomme juste à droite
oh non non non non aux autres on
contrôle le bonhomme bleu juste à droite
des le budget c'est de faire tomber
l'autre ou de l'envoyer hors du cercle
alors oui la maniabilité est à chier
voyez-vous n'arrête pas de se péter la
gueule
merde est en fait le but du jeu est de
faire tomber le plus de fois où je le
mette en obtient le plus de voix alors
dépendra des trucs assez d'offres à bata
merde
oh [ __ ] j'ai vu c'est quoi la touche
pour pousser avec la main où il fait
quoi il fait qu est ce qui fait qu
est-ce qui fait il appel au secours
maman maman à un moment je suis sur le
cul au maintenant je danse la macarena
c'est tellement un 19e gala c'est un
petit jeu gratuit évidemment je veux
enfin pays pour ça serait quand même
assez lent comme en fait non tiens coup
de tête
non non oui vous l'avez eue non
alors oui oh oui on se relaie dans sept
camps sur ses fesses non non non c'est
un duel d'autistes mais c'est juste
énorme quoi aller relève toi
bref quoi ap la tête dans les fesses oui
où
ah ça cartonne ce jeu je vous dis c'est
vraiment d'avoir essayé de le rejoindre
allez allez allez ouais tiens
non non non non on revient bien oui on y
va annoncer la fin aux [ __ ] c'est
tellement épique je vous jure times n 3
1 mais il faut qu'on gagne la faune
gagne madame c'est parti ben non mais
comment on pousse non non oui oh oui on
a gagné je suis pas comment c'est
possible on a gagné
allez on y retourne me retourne on tape
le seul état que tu tape tape tape le
sol de ce jeu non mais moi je suis pas
comment mais les modes la triche allez
relevant nous howick les bras à je lui
fais une prise de catch bouchenak
super gros jeux débiles que j'ai vu de
plus car tu es plus que j'y joue à des
jeux tout simplement au bulletin allez
on y retourne c'est reparti non mais
comment madame en retirant oui j'y mets
la main tiens tiens prise de karaté
non mais je m'allonge sur toi oh non non
non ils pètent dessus l'autre nom relève
ou non
alors que le truc qui peut être très
drôle avec ce jeu aussi bon là
malheureusement mon frère est en
vacances et pas chez moi c'est qu'on
peut jouer à plusieurs
vous pouvez jouer à deux par bompas
plusieurs plusieurs en co op
elle vous fait vous fait à quelqu'un
d'autre famille ouest affrontent sur
sumotori et et après hop c'est parti
vous l'affrontez sur sumotori et en
faites pas vous je m'adonne non merde
tiens tiens au nom au game over au nom
est en fait oui donc vous jouer à deux
sur le même clavier en fait on a perdu
il a gagné 5,3 il a gagné 5 3 nuls moi
je veux qu'on en fasse une un peu une
plus juste une manche où ils mangent
qu'on lui mette n'a bien dans les fesses
parce que là ça va pas du tout backspace
c'est quoi ça aïe ça ok vas-y tu tiens
tiens tiens au nom de dieu m'en fous je
me relève je mets un coup de tête je
m'arrête je mets un coup de tête relève
toi
ouais c'est ça reste parterre wesh non
non lordat
quand tu commences à jouer à ce jour
contre eux tu te royal manche et que tu
vois je tu es obligé de te pas t'arrêter
tellement c'est drôle non matin non mais
le trop fort il a su qu'il a été
entraîné par kakashi à l'aller vas-y tu
tapes par terre et tu te tape tape tape
le sol bim 'tabs pop' allez ciao chiens
non à la fois salle tout est attentif
salto bon en tout cas si vous voulez
jouer le jeu tout seul ou avec votre
famille n'hésitez pas au même avec un
pote à vous n'hésitez pas le lien est
dans la description
c'était une petite vidéo très content
vous présenter ce jeu qui m'a totalement
fédérer quand je les abris what you
wanna fuck
et puis ou au lait pied dans les fesses
et pied dans les fesses qu'elle suivait
testud fait où tu vas où tu m'as il à
temps normal et puis voilà john tout le
monde puisse à bientôt
ok